The joe rogan experience.
They're ridiculous.
I never seen ball so big in my life.
It doesn't even make sense.
Yeah.
Which brings me up to a very important point.
Check this out my next door.
Oh,
I don't want to say that.
Some people that I know.
Nice.
Can I say it?
The people that I know,
they're very nice people.
There's this gay couple,
they,
they had a kid and they impregnated a woman with their loads and the way they
did it was they put their loads together and then they mixed it up and then they
squirt it in fall.
It was like,
I'm,
they're off.
And it was just like,
hopefully it's my,
it's fucking shit.
What's fascinating about that?
I mean it's fascinating about that cause it's kind of weird.
Like they,
they really did,
they didn't just adopt a baby.
They created a baby with their own genetics.
Like they have a couple somehow or another.
I mean they'll figure out eventually whose baby it really is,
you know,
especially if they get in fights or something like that.
But the idea is that somehow or another,
you know you're going to figure out,
you know,
you're going to get this,
these loads in there and then it's gonna,
you know,
they're going to just have a race,
but they're not going to have a race.
They're going to murder each other.
Like a big percentage of the loads that you shoot are just murderous sperm
killers.
They're all they want to do is go kill other sperm.
They're sent out there to make sure that the sperm is already in the cooter.
It doesn't get to the eggs.
And so they attack and they go smash it.
And the more promiscuous the women are,
the more your body produces more of these crazy killer sperm.
That's why ball size is directly proportional to female slots in the community.
So like that's why gorillas have little balls.
Gorillas have little balls because female gorillas are chill.
They're not horse.
Chimpanzees have giant balls because female chimps are fucking whores.
They're whores.
They just want chimp,
Dick all over town Kerry.
And so these chimps have to force those killer loads in there so that their
genetics can move on to attack the loads.
So these guys in creating this baby,
they really launched this sperm fucking genocide campaign where they just
attacked each other.
The dish.
Oh my God.
You know,
there's no harmony in the in that there is no harmony in the,
you never should do.
They should have like a like seethrough flashlights and then let's all fuck it
and there'll be like an ant farm and we'll just watch all this shit to go down
on the fighter.
The sperm.
Wow.
I wonder if you could that's told.
True,
right.
I don't know if you were like,
you know like you,
you had a box and you can only,
well you don't want her to see each other while you're shooting loads,
but if you,
you had like something like on [inaudible] Room,
Bluetooth like video,
maybe it's like years a hole in the wall and the fleshlight is attached to the
hole in the wall and you're in one room fucking it and your friends and another
one fucking and it falls into the center and that's the catch tray.
And then it mixes them all together under some super powerful microscope and we
would watch sperm wars,
sperm wars.
If you imagine that would be like,
let's just,
let's just pitch it,
pitch it,
dude.
Least set up a meeting and just pitch it around.
How I see the look on people's faces.
It's like you want me to put our names on it?
Let me just say we're totally committed to this show.
Like this is our,
this is our fucking dream for Morris.
It's actually a good idea for a show.
You could have a show where you took celebrities and you,
you,
you shot their loads.
You know,
they do this,
you know,
they don't,
they don't have to actually do it.
You know,
you just pretend they're doing it and then the animate what's going on with
their loads.
Yeah,
that'd be sweet.
You know,
like Dwayne the Rock Johnson versus Brock Lesnar,
get their loads together and battle it out.
You could have like fucking Daniel Day Lewis versus fucking Jeremy Irons.
Ooh,
I like that.
One class a sperm fight.
A classy,
a fucking method.
Sperm,
English accent and sperms.
Sperms.
So white gloves.
Yeah.
Tool.
Perhaps.
I do.
Well,
that's semen duo too.
Okay.
Ah,
freaks and Geeks.
Lovers and children.
What's going on.